[Music]
[Music]
at MIT there was always a desire to
elevate the Arts Jerry Wiesner very
specifically would say you can't do good
engineering without the Arts he really
believed that the arts were integral to
a good education the film section
actually started because of a class that
had Pincus ran out of his studio in
central square and so many students at
MIT signed up for it that the powers
that be decided that they should move it
to the main campus and find their
well-known filmmaker who could head the
film section that was McKee Tanaka was
first asked by Jerry Wiesner to come
teach film video of MIT I was very
hesitant he rephrased them and said what
do you think that a place like MIT could
contribute to the art of filmmaking and
it's for this reason that we take very
seriously the effect of technology on
the creation
Ricky is often described as being the
father of cinema verite he became a
documentary filmmaker very early in life
I think he made his first film at age 14
well I love about the kind of filming
with I have spent my life doing is that
there are always surprises you always
have a preconceived idea of what you
think is going to happen and it's as you
see that preconception disintegrating
and the film becoming something entirely
different that you delight the film
section actually started as an
undergraduate program it didn't take
graduates until three years into the
program so we had introduction to
filmmaking intermediate filmmaking and
advanced filmmaking and students flocked
to it
so in terms of its relationship with the
student body it was
a very happening endeavor students love
the technology they loved being able to
express themselves and they loved the
adventure I think of going out of MIT to
try to tell a story that wasn't in their
immediate life the students shared they
shared their techniques
there was a very relaxed feeling but
there was also a driven feeling of
everyone wanting to go out and make a
film this film it was a wide open
program of asking people to let us film
aspects of that private life that they
wanted filmed this requires an awful lot
of energy all the way through the tongue
Ricky wanted to make double system
equipment so that anyone could make a
documentary film that they were
interested in making I came to MIT to
work on super ade and I couldn't
understand why you couldn't sync sound
recording that you made on a tape
recorder with the film that came out of
a super 8 film camera MIT had the answer
[Music]
another room the film/video section
became the venue for artists to come to
and want to screen their films for our
audience the Monday night screenings
where I was open to the public
Mary Jane Dougherty who made the
funniest films that were released I mean
she really had a wonderful sense of
humor this is an experimental
astrophysics laboratory heavy double
stars that the rotate around each other
you know
garetty waves and this is what ray is
looking for
I think the move to the Media Lab it was
by choice but it was also sort of
self-evident that we needed to go there
if we were going to invent some of the
new technologies and the new approaches
to video and that's of course what MIT
is all about it's about invention and
moving on to the new in terms of film
video it was very clear to me and to a
few others at the section at that time
that computers were going to totally
change how we edited
[Music]
Ricci himself I think was not so
interested in staying long-term at MIT
he wanted to go off and make more of the
type of movies he'd been talking about
using the video 8 technology and just
see what you would make if you hung out
on the streets of Paris one of the
really strong memories I have of the
film section in the film video section
and even my groups here the interactive
cinema group are all the fantastic
people who went through it really was
remarkable particularly in the early
days I think there wasn't anything like
that in the country there are many very
accomplished filmmakers who came out of
the film section Ross McElwee robb maus
Steve Asher
Burnie Schneider Alex Anthony Mary Jane
Dorothy very strong and and just many
more moving through into the days of the
Media Lab as well yeah
very influential
[Music]
you